another step then is in the 2030s
when we can actually
connect our neocortex which is where we
do our thinking
to
computers
and i mean just as this actually gains a
lot to being connected to
computers that will amplify its
abilities
i mean if this did not have any
connection it would be pretty stupid it
could not answer any of your questions
if you're just listening to this by the
way
ray's holding up
the the all-powerful
smartphone so we're going to do that
directly from our
brains i mean these are pretty good
these already have amplified our
intelligence i'm already much smarter
than i would otherwise be if i didn't
have this
because i remember when i first spoke
the age of intelligent machines
um
there was no way to get
information from computers i actually
would go to a library find a book
find the page that had an information i
wanted
and i go to the copier and my most
significant
uh
information tool was a roll of quarters
where i could feed
the copier
so
we're already
greatly advanced that we have these
things
there's a few problems with it first of
all i constantly put it down and i don't
remember where i put it
i've actually never lost it but
you have to find it
then you have to turn it on so there's a
certain amount of steps it would
actually be quite useful
if someone would just listen to your
conversation
and say uh
oh that's
you know so-and-so actress and tell you
what you're talking about so going from
active to passive where it just
permeates
your whole life yeah exactly the way
your brain does when you're awake
your brain is always there
right now that's something that could
actually just just about be done today
where you would listen to your
conversation understand what you're
saying understand what you're
not missing and give you that
information
but another step is to actually go
inside your brain yeah
and there are some
prototypes where you can connect your
brain
they actually don't have the amount of
bandwidth that we need
they can work but they work fairly
slowly
so if it actually would connect to your
neocortex
and the neocortex which i
described how to create a mind
the neocortex is actually
it has different levels and as you go up
the levels
it's kind of like a pyramid the top
level is fairly small
and that's the level where you want to
connect
these
brain extenders
um
so i believe that will happen in the
2030s we will actually
so just the way this is
greatly amplified by being connected to
the cloud
uh we can connect our own brain to the
cloud and
uh
just do what we can do by using this
machine
do you think it would look like uh the
brain computer interface of like
neuralink so would it be well never like
it's an attempt to do that
it doesn't have the bandwidth that we
need
um yet right right but i think
i mean they're going to get permission
for this because there are a lot of
people who absolutely need needed
because they can't communicate i know a
couple of people like that who
have ideas and they cannot
they don't
they cannot move their muscles and so on
they can't communicate
so for them this would be very valuable
but we could all use it
basically it'd be
uh
turn us into something that would be
like we have a phone but it would be in
our minds it would be kind of
instantaneous and maybe communication
between two people would not require
this low bandwidth mechanism of language
yes spoken word exactly
we don't know what that would be
although we do know that
computers can share information
like language instantly
they can share
many many books in a second
so we could do that as well
if you look at what our brain does
it actually
can manipulate different parameters
so we we talk about these large language
models
um
i mean i had written that
uh
it requires a certain
amount of information in order to
uh be effective
and that we would not see
ai really being effective until it got
to that level
and we had large language models there
were like 10 billion bytes didn't work
very well they finally got to 100
billion bytes and now they work fairly
well and and now we're going to a
trillion bytes
if you say uh
lambda has a hundred a billion bytes
what does that mean well what
what if you had something that had one
byte one one parameter
maybe you want to tell whether or not
something's uh
an elephant or not
and so you put in something that would
detect its trunk
if it has a trunk it's an elephant if it
doesn't have a trunk it's not an
elephant that will work
fairly well there's a few problems with
it
uh and really wouldn't be able to tell
what the trunk is but anyway and maybe
other things other than elephants have
trunks
you might get really confused yeah
exactly uh i'm not sure which animals
have trunks but you know
that's how you define a trunk
but yeah that's one parameter
you can do okay so these things have a
hundred billion parameters so they're
able to deal with very complex issues
all kinds of trunks
human beings actually have a little bit
more than that but they're getting to
the point where they can emulate humans
um
if we were able to connect this to our
neocortex
we would basically add
more of these uh abilities to make
distinctions
and it could ultimately be much smarter
and also be attached to information that
we feel is reliable
um so that's where we're headed so you
think that there will be a merger in the
30s
an increasing amount of merging between
the either human brain and the
ai brain
exactly
and the ai brain is really an
emulation of human beings i mean that's
why we're creating them
because human beings act the same way
and this is basically to amplify them i
mean this amplifies our brain
um
it's a little bit clumsy to interact
with but it definitely
it's a
you know way beyond what what we had 15
years ago
but the implementation becomes different
just like a bird versus the airplane
the even though the ai brain is an
emulation
it starts adding features we might not
otherwise
have like ability to consume a huge
amount of
information quickly like look up
thousands of wikipedia articles in one
take
exactly and we can get
for example issues like simulated
biology where it can
uh simulate
many different things at once
we already had one example of simulated
biology which is the moderna vaccine
and that's going to be now the way in
which we create
medications
but they were able to simulate
what each
example of an mrna would do to a human
being and they were able to simulate
that quite reliably
and we actually simulated billions of
different mrna sequences
and they found the ones that they were
the best and they created the vaccine
and they did and talked about doing that
quickly
they did that in two days
now how long would a human being take to
simulate billions of different mrna
sequences i i don't know that we could
do it at all but it would
take many years
they did it in two days
and
one of the reasons that people didn't
like vaccines
is because it was done too quickly it
was done too fast
and they actually included the time it
took to test it out which is 10 months
so
so they figured okay it took 10 months
to create this
actually it took us two days
and we also will be able to ultimately
do the tests in in a few days as well
oh because we can simulate how the body
will respond to it yeah more that's a
little bit more complicated because the
body's
has a lot of different
elements and we have to simulate all of
that but that's coming as well
so ultimately we could create it in a
few days and then test it in a few days
and it would be done
and we can do that with every type of
medical ins you know insufficiency that
we have
so curing all diseases
yeah
improving
certain functions of the body
supplements drugs
for recreation for health for
performance for productivity all that
well that's where we're headed
because i mean right right now we have a
very inefficient way of creating these
new medications
um
but we've already shown it and the
modern vaccine is actually the best
of the vaccines we've had
and it literally took two days to create
and we'll get to the point where we can
test it out also quickly
you